hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast integration of the
complexity difícil direct assay into a
two-step algorithm for the laboratory
diagnosis of c difficile presented by
our keynote presenter James Snyder PhD
professor of pathology in Laboratory
Medicine University of Louisville I am
Christina Mahalo collaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laborat
bobrucz is the leading scientific social
networking website in a producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions at you as
you want anytime you what during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen professor Snyder will be
following up with your questions via
email also please notice that you will
be viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the slide window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational unless office continuing
education credits and will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
of 2018 please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to obtain your credit now please
join me in welcoming professor James
Snyder I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you
it's an honor to be able to spend some
time with you during this webinar or
keynote address and I'd like to thank
lab roots
as well as Dias or and molecular for
sponsoring this keynote address I hope
by the end of this presentation you'll
have an appreciation of the serious
nature and the challenge that we are
facing with regards to both the
laboratory as well as the clinical
diagnosis of cluster idiom difficile
infection I'm going to be speaking
actually two parts number one give you
an overview of C difficile disease and
focus secondly on the laboratory aspects
where we evaluated a relatively new
molecular technology known as the dias
or in excel liaison c diff pcr formally
known as the simplex system and we're
going to be talking about how we have
evaluated it and how it fits into our
algorithmic approach to the laboratory
diagnosis of CDI this is a photo of the
University of Louisville hospital where
the hospital itself is the primary
teaching institution for the University
of Louisville Medical School the
hospital is primarily known for trauma
and essentially as a trauma driven
hospital then in essence it is basically
analogous to what we normally refer to
as the city county hospital we also have
a bone marrow transplant center located
in the hospital as well as in the cancer
center adjacent to the main facility
here I should also mention the fact that
we recently consolidated two
laboratories the University of
Louisville laboratory in which I direct
the microbiology and molecular
diagnostics program and merged the
laboratory with another local hospital
resulting in the volume of specimen
testing
nearly tripling we were in there about
our tenth month of this consolidation
and as you can appreciate integrating
personnel from two different
institutions medical staffs and etc it's
not an easy task but it's a challenging
and really have to be honestly it was a
fun task to interact with so many people
and bring forward a program of rapid
response rapid diagnostics and improved
quality of especially laboratory testing
which we hope will translate into better
patient care and savings to the
institution the objectives for our
keynote address today are listed there
for you and we'll give you a little
overview the epidemiology and the
incidence of this serious infection will
summarize some of the assays that are
available in both conventional as well
as molecular go over our study
evaluation design share with you our
results and conclude with comments
related to the performance of the
technology and related applications to
patient management in terms of
epidemiology as everyone knows or should
know C difficile accounts for a
predominant number or is the leading
cause of infectious diarrhea in the US
healthcare environment and a counselor
approximately 15 to 25 percent of
infectious diarrhea approximately 450
3,000 individuals are affected each year
with a mortality of approximately 29,000
deaths in terms of the current
statistics and it's also important to
look at the financial impact from the
cases alone it's been estimated that one
case
cost approximately nine thousand to
thirteen thousand dollars the infection
is caused by a bacterium known as
Clostridium difficile plus tree and
difficile is a member of the Clostridium
general and Clostridium difficile is a
gram positive spore forming rod and it's
an animal the organism is associated or
has two strains there's a toxigenic
strain and a nontoxigenic strain so
these toxin genic and nontoxigenic
strain can be found in the host where
they survive in the colon
the toxigenic strain is the most
important one of the two in that it
produces toxins and the three toxins
that are produced by the toxigenic
strains include toxin a toxin B and
occasionally there are strains that will
produce the binary toxin sometimes
referred to as na p1o 27 and beot toxin
B is the most prominent toxin of the
three and accounts for the infectious
process in other words toxin B is
responsible for the associated diarrhea
following the activation of toxigenic
Clostridium difficile obviously as you
can appreciate and probably even read in
the papers C difficile has markedly
increased in most countries throughout
the world so it is a worldwide challenge
in the US alone estimated costs have
been between 500 million and 1.5 billion
dollars spent alone on C difficile
infections and is a major burden to the
hospital environment and
institution in general when it comes to
laboratory diagnosis and I want to make
it very clear there is a difference
between laboratory diagnosis and
clinical diagnosis the laboratory
diagnosis is independent of the clinical
diagnosis we're going to be focusing on
the laboratory diagnosis and when you
hear term sensitivity and specificity
from the laboratory perspective we're
evaluating the analytical sensitivity
specificity and etc which does not
relate to the clinical sensitivity and
specificity I think it would be good
idea if we consider reviewing the
differences between clinical and and
analytical metrics such as sensitivity
specificity predictive value and etc so
when we come to the point of laboratory
diagnosis we have a couple options
available to us in the form of
conventional methods or molecular and of
course molecular technology is becoming
widely used in the laboratory diagnosis
of a variety of infectious diseases when
we focus on conventional methods the two
methods that had been used for years or
the toxigenic culture and the cell
culture side of toxicity sometimes
referred to as the cell culture
cytotoxicity neutralization a say the
toxigenic culture is designed to recover
the organism Clostridium difficile once
the organism is recovered in culture
then that isolate is tested for its
ability to produce toxin the cell site
pox at site of toxicity or C or the cell
culture site of sex of you the cell
culture cytotoxicity
neutralization assay is used to detect
the toxin once again remember the toxin
is the primary very lence factor but the
toxigenic culture and the cytotoxicity
assay are regarded as gold standards
when evaluating technologies designed to
detect clustering difícil additional
conventional methods which have become
very prominent in the laboratory today
are the enzyme immunoassay tests
beginning with the glutamate
dehydrogenase test this is an antigen
that is carried by both the toxigenic
and the nontoxigenic strain
thus the gdh assay does not
differentiate between toxigenic and
nontoxigenic strain then we have the
enzyme immunoassay designed to detect
toxin once again primarily toxin b toxin
a may be there but it's toxin B that is
the most responsible virulence factor in
causing the disease toxin a is
essentially a secretory toxin which
essentially allows the entry of toxin B
into the mucosal lining and can promote
then the activity of toxin B in
producing active infectious diarrhea
then we have molecular methods sometimes
referred to as NAT nucleic acid
amplification test two of the most
prominent
NAT tests or the loop mediated
isothermal amplification and the other
being and most prominently use is the
PCR nucleic acid amplification both
systems are molecular in nature and are
capable of detecting toxigenic
Clostridium difficile
sill and I think one thing we need to
remember is when we're talking about
these molecular methods they detect the
gene and they cannot differentiate
between toxigenic and or toxin producing
organisms but detect the genes that code
for the production of toxin whether or
not that gene is active or actively
coding for the production of toxin
depends upon the use of a toxin
detection assay such as a enzyme
immunoassay for toxin a and B the
molecular methods are very popular today
and there are two schools of thought
regarding the laboratory testing for c
difficile one school of thought is the
use of PCR for direct testing no other
tests needed the second school of
thought is an algorithmic approach and
we have elected to go with the
algorithmic approach which I will
present to you in a moment with the
gorse to our study design and I remind
you this was an evaluation this was not
an in-depth high volume sample study it
was designed to determine or ask the
question can the disor and PCR
instrument or technology perform at a
level comparable to other PC ARS and be
integrated successfully into an
algorithmic testing format so in our
study the first criteria was the sample
being a stool but specifically it must
be a liquid stool a stool that conforms
to the shape of the vessel in which it's
been placed and or conforms to the shape
of the vessel and they involved all
hospitalized adults the specimens were
tested prospectively within 24 hours
they were not
delayed beyond 24 hours and were stored
at 4 degrees in our laboratory we use an
algorithmic approach for the detection
of the c.difficile
and you can call it a two step three
step depending on the circumstances the
two step is essentially involving an
enzyme immunoassay which is packaged as
a kit involving glutamate dehydrogenase
testing for the antigen and the toxin
toxin a and B in our laboratory doing
the gene eh and the toxin if both are
positive we do not do confirmatory
testing it is a final result if the
glutamate dehydrogenase is positive and
the toxin is negative that flexes to
conformation using a PCR so the PC ours
that are used in this evaluation for
primarily or for confirmation but to
enhance the value of the study we did
PCR on every specimen err regardless of
the glutamate dehydrogenase toxin
results once again gdh if it happens to
be negative and no toxin was positive we
would confirm with PCR if both the gdh
and the toxin are negative no additional
testing was done so in our evaluation
three molecular assays were involved the
first as you can see great basin was the
technology that we had been using in our
laboratory for four or five years and
since our in-house method and that was
used at for confirmatory testing only we
also included in the evaluation the
expert infinity from the
Cepheid Phil folks and the primary focus
was on the DIA Sauron a say the
c.difficile direct a say from the
assorted molecular so our goal was was
to basically ask the question does the
c.difficile direct assay fit very well
into an algorithmic testing format in a
laboratory I remind you again that all
specimens were tested directly with PCR
the exception being with our Great Basin
so we continued in our standard format
with our GD H toxin and if necessary
confirm with a Great Basin but all the
specimens were tested directly with both
the expert infinity and the dais or an
apparatus what you're looking at is the
dias or an instrument known as the
liaison and DX and the system is is very
conveniently from a space point of view
accommodated in the laboratory you'll
notice there are fish there is a disk
and that is the focus of the testing
platform in the system and the next
slide will show you how this assay is
prepared and placed on the disk for
detection and the the instrument itself
so you simply take the the stool sample
you dip a swab into that sample and
remove any access stool by pressing the
swab against the inside of the container
and then you swirl that swab in a sample
prep solution known as a buffer and
deposit or discard the swab followed by
scanning the simplex a reaction mix or
master mix and the also scanned the
amplification disk and
the patient ID this goes into the
computer assistant database and is a
very slick system the second step is to
pipette the specimen once you lift the
top or the foil from the well the you
pipette the direct reaction mix into the
designated are well as it says there and
then pipette the diluted patient sample
into the sample well the disc is reseal
with foil and we tear off the perforated
edge and place the disc in the device or
platform and close the lid and within
about an hour you will have your results
printed out electronically and simply
you can click Save and then click the
run so as a result of that it's a about
an hour hour and 15 minute test time
it's user friendly minimal hands-on time
which is important from a labour
perspective once again this is our
algorithmic approach and just to review
that force we're looking at the
laboratory diagnosis of c difficile
using a two step method involving
glutamate dehydrogenase and toxin
detection so you can see the various
results across the top beginning with
the positive gdh and a toxin positive
the report would go out it's Clostridium
difficile infection is likely if we have
a negative gdh but a toxin positive test
that would indicate CDI is likely or we
would also flex to confirm with PCR if
we have a positive gvh and a negative
toxin that also is flexed for
confirmatory testing using PCR and if
the gdh is negative and the toxin is
negative we report that cd-i is on
likely so from the pcr perspective we
either detect or we don't detect the
gene and once again it's important to
note that the the PCR does not detect
toxin and cannot differentiate between
active disease and or a carrier or
colonization state of the patient very
important aspect to remember if doing
direct PCR I should also mention there
are studies coming out that indicate how
better to utilize PCR is a direct assay
and that's for another lecture but at
this time let's look at our data as I
indicated in the beginning we did not
have a huge sample size by statistical
purposes a total of 196 specimens were
eligible for testing in the evaluation
and you can see the breakdown the
results
beginning with glutamate dehydrogenase
positive toxin positive there were a
total of 11 now because the Great Basin
was used as only a confirmatory test and
there are normal conditions it was not
tested under that circumstance however
noting that the stools were also tested
directly between the dye essaouira
formerly simplex them and the Cepheid
infinity you can see of the eleven that
were detected the Thea Soren detected
all eleven positives as well as the
Infinity very good correlation there
those that were gdh positive and toxin
negative there were approximately are
there were 25 as you can see of those 25
15 in confirmatory testing my Great
Basin were regarded as positive 10 or
negative versus the simplex a-- or the
DA Soren which 15 and 10 respectively so
the the compare
the index test in this case the Great
Basin the integrated cycler dear Sauron
agreed 100% the infinity picked up one
additional positive so is this a false
positive or a true positive well to
answer that question we would have had
they've done either a toxigenic culture
or cell cytotoxicity neutralization
assay which we did not do and nine of
those were negative so the question is
was that positive a true positive or a
false positive those that were
completely negative for above gdh and
toxin once again and you would not test
those with your your index test in this
case the Great Basin but the dear Sauron
picked up two additional positives
versus 157 that were negative and the
infinity picked up three additional
positives with 156 being negative so the
question once again is are these true
positives or false positives and doing
either toxigenic culture and or toxin
analysis with the cell cytotoxicity
neutralization si would have answered
that question we did encounter one
situation where the gdh was negative but
the toxin was positive and once again
with the Great Basin the the result was
positive and for the simplex as well as
for the Infinity they respectively
detected his positive that which was
toxin positive by our two-step algorithm
so once again there's pretty good
correlations you can see there to kind
of break down the data and its entirety
in terms of specifically the agreement
the deus orang simplex a-- probably
should update my slides verses a Cepheid
infinity overall over 28 positives two
negatives there were one negative and
100
sixty-four I'm sorry one positive by
infinity 164 were negative and once
again there were 29 positives versus 166
which adds up to the total number of
tested the point here is that overall
the percent agreement was very very good
now we did not do statistical analysis
in regards to sensitivity specificity
predicted value and what we were looking
at was Agrifac recei and the positive
percent agreement the negative percent
agreement and overall as you can see
they were overall it was a very good
correlation between the respective
molecular instruments and the data is
very very good so with regards through
current guidelines a lot of people been
asking about where are guidelines
available today to assist laboratories
and clinicians with regards to
diagnosing accurately clustering and
difficile infection well the current
guidelines are those of the European
guidelines that you can see listed there
these guidelines are a couple of years
older nearly two years old but are
available on the web as well as in the
reference that is cited there for you
the European guidelines advocate a two
step or three step approach with PCR
being used either in the two step or as
a confirmatory testing in other words if
you do PCR and as part of the two steps
some laboratories will do the PCR first
and if the PCR is positive then they
will flex two toxin assay usually an
enzyme immunoassays so it can be used in
that format or it can be used as a
confirmatory test
following the to step out of rhythm
involving the the antigen and the toxin
EIA s once again
the European guidelines endorse that
either way I should mention that the
America cited for Microbiology is in the
final stages of actually writing an
evidence-based guideline on C difficile
testing the focus is primarily on
diagnostic accuracy the algorithmic
approach versus or along with the direct
PCR we anticipate that publication to be
in print by early to mid spring and I
can tell you without any reservations
we're going to finalize the document in
the next few days and submit it for
publication the IDSA is is revising
their current guidelines the one that
you see listed there doesn't go a lot
into laboratory assays it's more patient
management infection control and etc so
as a result of that the new updated
version I'm not sure when that will be
due but IDSA is revising their
guidelines so before we summarize what
we've been talking about today I'd like
to go over for a few moments the
advantages and limitations or strengths
and weaknesses of the current clustering
and testing methods and I'll start with
the nucleic acid test nucleic acid tests
have a very high sensitivity and as a
result of the high sympathetic
sensitivity it over calls or increases
the rates of c difficile disease once
again remember that the molecular assays
cannot differentiate between
colonization and active CDI so if you're
doing direct PCR and the high
sensitivity associating that technology
has a tendency to over call and inflate
the rates of clustering difficile
infection that is very very important
from
perspective of reimbursement basically
most of you or maybe all of you are
familiar with the CMS guidelines known
as value-based purchasing and our
penalizing institutions that have
excessive CDI rates and by virtue of the
peddles penalties they are losing
reimbursement and are losing a lot of
dollars if you will so that has to be
considered one of the considerations as
to whether or not we should be doing
direct PCR I'm not going to answer that
question today but once again something
to consider as members of different
institutions in infection fection
control
he didn't also effects antibiotic
utilization all of which adds up to cost
but there are some positives to direct
PCR as well and before I get to those
keep in mind molecular tests are
expensive they are not cheap so we have
to take that into consideration with
regards to how we approach our C
difficile testing to remind you once
again the molecular technologies in this
case detect the gene that codes for the
toxin but does not detect the toxin
itself and dust once again cannot
differentiate colonization from active
disease overall the molecular assays for
c diff like any molecular assay lack
clinical specificity and when you have
this deficiency in clinical specificity
it inflates your CDI rates and the
consequences that I just mentioned with
regards to reimbursement and excessive
cost to the institution on the positive
side if you will in addition to being
highly sensitive molecular assays use
for c difficile testing may promote
better infection control measures it
they promote better utilization of
antibiotics for example withholding
antibiotics if the test is negative and
it will have a positive influence on
antimicrobial stewardship programs in
general if we look at the advantages and
the limitations of our more conventional
AIAS gdh and EIA in this case I think
it's important to realize that glutamate
dehydrogenase is as modestly or somewhat
less sensitive than your nucleic acid
tests and your toxin assays less
sensitive for a variety of reasons in
that for a positive test you need a
certain organism load and if there are
very few organisms in that specimen it
may be below the sensitivity of the
assay itself it's been estimated that
gdh will probably miss or likely miss
20% of cases because of the low level of
inoculum or low quantity of organisms
that are in the specimen that would
indicate that the sensitivity of the
assay would account for that but this
has been found to be somewhat common in
patients designated as carriers they
have such a low organism load that the
gdh may miss those because of the lower
sensitivity and that is associated with
it on the other hand toxin tests are
less sensitive but much more specific so
if toxin is present it's been correlated
with the fact that the patient has a has
a more active disease a more challenging
prognosis and would probably account for
additional days in the hospital so great
specificity less sensitive they are
rapid and of course they were less
expensive once again the financial and
which the laboratory has to be accounted
for in terms of its overall expenses so
as I said to gdh misses approximately 20
percent of the positives that are
actually detected by the nucleic acid
test and even in patients with
symptomatic CDI but a take negative test
reminds you does not rule out
Clostridium difficile infection so our
recommendation is an algorithmic testing
involving the two-step gdh enzyme
immunoassay and using molecular testing
or not as a confirmatory in those cases
where the EIA is a negative we find it
to be very helpful we have noticed that
by doing this we have reduced our
overall rates of CDI and to even further
improve our testing and relationship to
patient management we created a
checklist that the physician and/or
nurse must complete that list criteria
for eligibility of that stool specimen
to be tested in the laboratory and that
checklist is sent to the laboratory and
reviewed once again by the testing
technologist and to ensure that it meets
the eligibility for testing some of the
clinical criteria and I think it's very
important to remind everyone there has
yet to be developed a formal clinical
and laboratory definition of Clostridium
difficile infection that is true
infection it does not exist so from the
clinical criteria today we utilize such
criteria as greater than three stools
liquid stools per day if the patient's
been on a laxative for the last 48 hours
the test is not or is not performed the
specimen is not eligible had they had an
antibiotic history of the last two weeks
and
criteria like that are currently
acceptable but certainly we are in need
of a defined more formal definition of
the clinical aspects of the infection as
well as the laboratory definition so by
way of summary the the respective
systems that were evaluated with the
primary focus being on the Deus ORN
system there was a complete agreement
between the disor and the gene expert
with our in-house 2 step 3 step
algorithm there was overall agreement of
greater than 98% between the expert
system and the simplex itself excellent
data and overall we think that the Deus
oran system or technology would
integrate very well with an algorithmic
testing format such as the one that we
use in our laboratory so overall it's a
reliable method we would use it as a
confirmatory test only and once again
the algorithmic testing strategy is what
we follow
but once again the jury is still out
regarding the the use of direct PCR or
algorithmic approach hopefully some
publications that will be coming out in
the next year that will add
clarification to the situation that
we're currently dealing with and I can
honestly say that physicians are really
challenged when they get a positive PCR
result back and challenge from the
perspective do I treat it do I not treat
it and what does this all mean so we in
the laboratory have to be available to
work with the clinicians in addition to
our infectious disease personnel as well
as support our infection control and
prevention program as well as the animal
stewardship so we play a great role in
all those areas but once again we're
still not there yet with regards to what
is and what does not constitute true c
difficile infection I would currently
discourage standalone tests I would not
do a GD H alone I would not do a toxin
alone or what I do a molecular assay
alone obviously as we've been talking
about we recommend algorithmic testing
the two-stage involving the two assays
that are listed there for you and either
the GD H or the nucleic acid test and
followed by a toxin if you happen to get
a positive GD H or an positive molecular
assay we alluded to that earlier but
once again the the recommendation or the
preference is algorithmic test so I'd
like to acknowledge mr. Thompson Tina
Thompson she is our research
technologist she is responsible for the
actual conduct of this evaluation and
deserves a lot of recognition for
completion of this evaluation and
obviously Deus or molecular they
supplied the the platform the reagents
and I will also disclose that an
honorarium was provided for presentation
of the data thank you and would be happy
to answer any questions